there's a reason they didn't pick us  because it's an educational deal you  don't want to like put us in like our  Maps with strings right because we're  the smartest we're the brainiacs yeah  you know I only have to go off of what I  see but there's a bromance going on  between the Lincoln JJ playing JJ are  two peas in a pod you know they're  chilling by the pool cooking together  and just eating or whatever just sitting  on the couch you own me now and you hold  my wrist on but then you feel like if  you can't let my wristlet out but if  they're a block yes yes right there  blocked me in there Clinton JJ you  really just kind of had this one-on-one  vibe going  I mean it's like they got a little pep  in their step when they're together I  usually don't have to raise this I went  back well you squeeze a couple US met in  the shower I appreciate that I enjoy